all right so Christy wha-what what's
been going on you look so much better
than I've ever seen you I've seen you
for like almost a year now
well almost every day every other day
and you look great
thank you are you no longer in your tent
no tell me well um I just you know beat
in a tent you become too comfortable you
know and I you know I had to step up it
I just - probably a tent and you know
move forward you know step out of skid
Road as you say and you know I don't
know I'm I'm well well I'm not it's not
like I'm any better from an intent to
what but I'm I'm in the process of
getting housing I'm actually closer to
get it then I think you know well it's
what my caseworker said but I'm not
lettin negative people get to me I'm
well I'm still turning my dates but I'm
doing it a little more classy yeah just
yeah yeah I'm so you're still using
um I still get high but not like I used
to
so usually I use a little lot less yeah
being honest you know yeah what do you
think is causing these changes in you um
I just well I took a look at myself well
I mean yeah yeah yeah took a look at
myself and yeah and like that's you know
not at all
That's not me and I mean this right here
isn't even me
I mean I know what I used to look like
and everything and I know I can get back
to that you know so but you know step by
step you know getting there you're still
young
yeah I'm so yeah yeah you said your
daughter you sat down with your daughter
and watch the video yeah I watched a
video with my daughter and
you know and God I just you know what it
was like a reality check for me in and
Fermi you know just you know explaining
things to my daughter about my life and
you know I didn't you know I wanted to
tell her you know I didn't want her just
you know find out things you know but
you know letting her know about my life
and you know what I'm going through and
my family and you know her family you
know and yeah but I'm doing more
positive and I'm thinking positive and
I'm hanging out with different crowds
and yeah that's great that's so
refreshing to hear stories like this
because they're rare document yeah they
are you're going in the right direction
what do you think would help you further
to take it - well I mean if I had a half
like I mean honestly I mean if they
would speed up the process of getting me
into housing or like some you know
Latour I'm not in the streets you don't
I'm saying it like I would like I would
put I would throw it everything you know
to the curb we you know I'm saying it as
long as I know that you know I got like
for sure you know I can keep I can I can
pay my rent you know what I'm saying I
just need I just need a stepping stool
just sit that's it you know I'm saying
just you know just you know you know
just you know just something to get me
started so I get a stepping stool you
know and then I can sit there and
continue it all myself you know I'm
saying I just need you know just a
little you know
yeah then you'd get a place here on Skid
Row or somewhere else somewhere else
yeah skin roads over it's played out
played out before you got it
it sure was I'm just another face you
know another face another story yeah
that's a horrible life yeah but everyone
has their their story and you know no
one's better no one's you know that was
less you know we're all we all got our
our bruises and cuts and scars you know
in our stories to tell about it you know
well that's so refreshing to hear thank
you so much for their coming in and
talking about it yeah
thank you you know thank you you know
your up your website actually uh you
know it uh gives you an eye-opener you
know for real it does stories yeah but
you know what the thing though is it
that it's it's the truth it is all the
things that you know that we've gone
through and it's things that you know
that that people don't take the time out
to ask or try to you know get to know or
they don't even know about these people
you know what I'm saying
that if they knew things that you know
that happened to people you know I'm
saying that they would know the reasons
why they're going through the things
that they're going through you don't I'm
saying so they would sit there and
understand that we're not just bums or
we're not you know just drug addicts
where you know people that's you know
going through some some issues that you
know that have you know of other you
don't know how to cope with things you
know but you know or some people that
you know don't have family anymore that
have no help or you know people that are
just lost yeah well you you looked
transformed
from that last video for sure yeah that
last video I mean I mean well a trick
you know sit there and you know I got
into it with the trick you know and mess
my face up in your speech the way you're
dressed the whole thing you look like oh
yeah turning a corner yeah yeah and that
that video was like you know you know I
have my opinion on it but still yeah I'm
just you know I have a I have a you know
I am like what do you think would help
you the most housing housing would help
me a housing it would help me the most
and like a program honestly I think a
program is a crutch but I mean but yet
you know other people you know may need
programs but honestly I feel that if a
person is ready to stop they're gonna
stop you know what I'm saying I don't
like to lie to myself you know what I'm
saying that but also a program also it
is you know a support you know some
people you support you know well like I
you know I do ya support I guess yeah I
mean what I heard your voice in previous
talks was a lot of self-pity and that's
what I'm not hearing today long like
today you're talking about like how to
improve and how to just kind of make the
steps towards that or where's in the
past you were just saying poor me poor
me poor me yeah that's a very different
that's a big change
yeah but I mean everyone gets to the
point when they're all like poor me you
know what I'm saying but
I mean yeah but you got to put your
big-girl panties on and deal with [ __ ]
you know thank you so much for talking
you